NATO Kriegsschiffe in der Ostsee die
Übung northern coasts im Herbst
2023 wo immer die westlichen Einheiten
unterwegs sind sind auch russische
Aufklärer nicht weit sie versuchen mit
neuester Technik sich in Datensysteme
und Smartphones auf den natoschiffen zu
Hecken der Tender Elbe vor der Küste
llands das Versorgungsschiff der
deutschen Marine ist in manöverfahrt
plötzlich die Meldung auf der Brücke
Person überbord
[Musik]
ein Soldat zeigt mit einer Flagge
permanent auf die Person im
[Musik]
Wasser al in
Position im Wasser treibt diesmal nur
ein dumy Übung wir sind hier in einem
militärischen Szenario unterwegs das
heißt also es besteht immer die
Möglichkeit eines Angriffes und
natürlich auch während eines Angriffes
kann es dazu kommen dass Personen über
Bord gehen und wir gehen ja davon aus
dass die Person die über Bord gegangen
ist bereits schon
unterkühlungserscheinung hat sich
vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so gut
bewegen kann und da ist ganz wichtig
dass wir da mer im Wasser haben der im
Zweifel dann unterstützen
kann mit einem speziellen Netz können
Personen relativ einfach ins
Rettungsboot gehieft werden seit der
Alarmierung sind nur wenige Minuten
vergangen übungsalltag auf einem
Kriegsschiff der Tender Elbe kann sein
Beiboot samt Besatzung aufnehmen solche
Übungen gehören zum Alltag an Bord so
können Abläufe verbessert werden fällt
auf wenn nicht ausreichend auf Details
geachtet wurde diesmal hat alles
geklappt ich bin zufrieden die Zeiten
waren wirklich sehr gut also der
Wachoffizier das Schiff sehr gut
beherrscht hat es schnell an den
verontfalten herangebracht und äh auch
die brotsbesatzung hat super reagiert
war sehr schnell ausgerüstet und waren
sehr schnell klar dazum ausgesetzt zu
werden und haben auch Vorort genau das
Richtige
getan genau das Richtige tun in der
Ostsee an den Küsten der baltischen
Republiken ist diese Maxime derzeit so
wichtig wie noch nie seit dem Ende der
Sowjetunion
Reise
Aufstehen ah Reise Reise Reise
aufstehen
die morgenidylle auf See trügt jede
Bewegung westlicher Kriegsschiffe wird
von Moskau beobachtet das ist jedem
Besatzungsmitglied auf der Elbe bewusst
seit dem ukrainekrieg herrscht auf
Schiffen der NATO wie wohl auch auf
russischer Seite höchste
Alarmbereitschaft wir alle schauen
deutlich genauer aufs Meer und nicht nur
auf die Horizontlinie sondern weiterüber
hinaus ich persönlich äh bin noch
angespannter und auch meine Soldaten und
soldatinen äh befinden sich jetzt in ein
Zustand einer ich nenn es jetzt mal
professionellen Anspannung ein
Zwischenfall könnte ein
Navigationsfehler sein es gibt die
kollisionsverhütungsregeln an die sich
jeder hält also quasi die
Straßenverkehrsordnung in See und das
bedeutet
wenn wir offensichtliche Fehler machen
könnte dies auch als Provokation
wahrgenommen also wir halten auf ein
russisches Fahrzeug zu z.B oder wir
halten uns zu streng an die
kollisionsverhütungsregeln um unser
Recht durchzubringen also hier heißt es
gesunder Menschenverstand an und
natürlich auch Abstand
halten vor allem dann wenn die NATO
Übungen durchführt wie im Herbst 2023
das Seemanöver northern coast geübt wird
teils vor den Küsten Lettlands und
Estlands teils aber auch in
dort sind auch russische Kriegsschiffe
unterwegs wie dieses russische
Aufklärungsschiff flotillenadmiral
Torsten marks weiß dass die Fregatte
Hessen von besonderem Interesse sein
dürfte sie ist das Flagschiff des
natoeinsatzverbandes auf Nord und
Ostsee Admiral Marx führt das Kommando
mit einem multinationalen ST in der
Ostsee begegnen sich schon immer
Kriegsschiffe der westlichen
anreinerstaaten und Russlands doch
zerstörte Gaspipelines und
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland so
wo sind wir denn haben die Situation
verschärft die Ostsee ist für die NATO
ein strategisches Gebiet mit den
wirtschaftsflüssen die durch die Ostsee
gehen der kritischen Infrastruktur die
in der ostseeheimat ist und natürlich
mit der Besonderheit dass in Russland
mit der oplas Kaliningrad auch einen
Stützpunkt in der Ostsee hat
kommt der Ostsee eine große Bedeutung zu
Deutschland ist sich dessen bewusst wir
haben große Expertise im Rahmen der
Ostsee das wird von den anderen
natoalliierten anerkannt die Fregatte
hessen gehört zur sachsenklasse sie
wurde 2005 in Dienst gestellt und ist
auf die Luftverteidigung spezialisiert
ihr Radar kann über 1000 Ziele also
Flugzeuge Drohnen oder Raketen
gleichzeitig erfassen die Reichweite
ihrer Waffensysteme bis zu 160 km die
NATO tritt bei ihren Einsätzen
nonkonfrontativ deeskalierend auf wir
haben kein Interesse da dran dass sich
die Situation weder in der Nordsee noch
in der Ostsee verschärft wir zeigen aber
sehr deutlich dass wir bereit sind mit
durchsetzungsfähigen Kräften
bündnisgebiet zu verteidigen sollte das
entsprechender Fall
sein hier sind wir in der neuen Bravo
Null alex ist hauptbootsmann und gehen
halt durch Richtung OPZ und
waffenleitmeister auf der Fregatte
Hessen äußerst selten wird die Erlaubnis
erteilt an seinem Arbeitsplatz zu filmen
der liegt tief im Rumpf der Fregatte
Zutritt selbst für Besatzungsmitglieder
nur mit
Sicherheitsfreigabe das ist ja die
Operationszentrale und ja als
gefächtsstand kann man es bezeichnen an
diesem Gerät bekämpfen wir andere
Schiffe oder können quasi die Bekämpfung
anderer Schiffe
vornehmen und hier findet die Planung
des ganzen
bekämpfungsprozesses statt
hier vorne werden dann die anderen zwei
Arbeitsplätze die mir zur Verfügung
stehen wo dann zwei Untergebene Soldaten
fürs feuerleitgefecht stehen die
bedienen jeweils das marine
Leichtgeschütz 27 mm auf der Steuerbord
und Backboard Seite und ich sitze da
drüben auf der anderen Seite und
kommuniziere über das Headset mit meinen
zwei unterstellten Soldaten hier vorne
und leite quasi von der 76 mm das hat
eristische
geepächt das Schießen läuft überwiegend
dann beim Lufts schießen über dieses
diesen Monitor ab auf diesem Bild wird
dann quasi sichtlich dass ein ein
Flugzeug anfliegend ist und auch ein
schlepptzi hinten ausgebracht hat ich
tracke quasi dann mit dem Joystick hier
vorne das Ziel an und halte dann quasi
auf das luftseh ein und
später drücke ich nur noch auf den
abfeuerungsknopf sbald ich dann halt das
Go bekomme soweit ich schießen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
darf während eines Manövers herrscht an
Bord noch mehr Betrieb als bei normaler
Einsatzfahrt auf der Ostsee die Übungen
mit anderen natoeinheiten dauern im
Herbst 2023 rund Z Wochen an Schiffe aus
ganz Europa und Nordamerika nehmen daran
teil
das Manöver soll Abläufe verbessern
Schwachstellen in der multinationalen
Zusammenarbeit
aufdecken für die bis zu 255
Besatzungsmitglieder heißt das
Dauerstress kurze Pause für Alex in der
sogenannten Messe für portep
Unteroffiziere die letzten Tage sehr
anstrengend mit wenig Schlaf verbunden
sehr viel Arbeit sehr viel
Vorbereitungszeit schießen muss
angemeldet werden 12 Stunden
Schichtdienst und schlaft dazwischen
vielleicht
sechs weil man schläft ja auch nicht am
Stück sondern immer nur geteilt
zwischenzeitlich muss man halt auch noch
was zu essen haben Mittag Frühstück
Abendessen und danach ist man wieder auf
Wache Freizeit Freizeit ist in den
letzten paar Tagen eher wenig bis gar
nicht
entweder verzichtet man dann halt auf
ein bisschen privates oder man schläft
für mirhr ist da tatsächlich nicht die
Zeit Alex kann sich wie viele seiner
Kameraden auch während seiner freie
Wache nicht immer allein in seine
Zweimann Kajüte zurückziehen gerade z.B
weil sein Kamerad dort
schläft nicht immer leicht sind die
Gedanken an zu Hause seit dem Einmarsch
Russlands in die Ukraine hat sich für
ihn nicht viel verändert sagt er aber
für seine
Angehörigen
die Familie macht sich dann schon ein
paar Gedanken dass es dann halt in die
Richtung gehen könnte und dass man dann
tatsächlich inen scharfen Einsatz
geschickt würde
aber aus meiner Sicht ist die Lage noch
ganz ruhig was uns
betrifft die NATO zeigt ihre Schlagkraft
in der Ostsee deutlich Teil der
Strategie Russland abzuschrecken die
Schiffe bleiben oft monatang in See
Kraftstoff wird während der Fahrt
gebunkert vom Tankschiff Spessert
bekommen eine französische Fregatte und
die Hessen zeitgleich Diesel allein bei
diesem Tankvorgang sind es 300.000
l die versorgungsboote halten die
schießenden Einheiten in
Gefechtsbereitschaft auch die Elbe
gehört zum versorgungsrückgrat für das
bootsgeschwader auf ihrer Brücke wird
gerade ein besonderes Manöver
vorbereitet ein dänischer Hubschrauber
soll über dem Flugdeck schweben und ein
Besatzungsmitglied per Seil Winde von
Bord
holen auf Befehl werden die jeweiligen
Flaggen und und tagssignale
gesetzt auch schon bereit quets habt ihr
bereit sehr gut die Vorbereitungen
organisiert Hendrik Kapitän Leutnant und
erster Wachoffizier ja zieh den mit ab
und dann schnellst möglich die Waffen
weg während des sogenannten winchex
Manövers darf aus Sicherheitsgründen
kein Bordgeschütz der Elbe geladen sein
windck wird meistens im Notfall
durchgeführt wenn wir einen verletzten
an Bord haben äh der schnell
ausgeschifft werden muss und ins
Krankenhaus muss weil es wirklich was
akutes ist das äh kann auch durchgeführt
werden halt einfach im schnellen im
schnellen Beritt weil es halt ein
Notfall dann ist als Übung bietet diese
Form von bordzugehen allerdings auch
eine ganze Menge Adrenalin und Abenteuer
wir werden auch einen Soldaten aus
unserer Besatzung Stellen einer der sich
drum verdient gemacht hat mal ein
Helikopter
mitzufliegen ist ein guter Mann hatte
letzte Woche einen sehr guten Job
gemacht und das ist jetzt so kleiner
goodi und so eine so ein Mitflug in so
einem Helikopter ist schon verdammt
cool jeder Handgriff wird bei den
Übungen einstudiert damit im Ernstfall
alles reibungslos
läuft was hier spielerisch leicht
aussieht fordert von allen Beteiligten
höchste Konzentration und Nerven aus
Stahl sobald die Person am Seil hängt
schwebt der Helikopter neben die Elbe
und zieht sie erst über dem Wasser an
Bord schon kleine fahr oder flugfehler
können bei dieser Übung zum Abbruch oder
Schlimmerem
führen diesmal klappt alles
problemlos
die dänische Hubschrauberbesatzung
verabschiedet sich von den deutschen
Marinesoldaten mit einem eleganten
[Musik]
Flugmanöver danach kehrt erstmal der
Alltag wieder ein auf dem Tender doch
auch der ist besonders an Bord eines
Versorgungs
die Atmosphäre innerhalb der Besatzung
unterscheide sich zu der auf anderen
Schiffstypen
ursprünglich wollte ich zu marinum zu
See zu fahren als ich noch als ich noch
jung war die die Abenteuerlust hat mich
gepackt
und ja ich wollte zur See fahren ich
wollte eentlich große Schiffe zur See
fahen große Schiffe Fregatte ganz viel
aber da meine ersten Erfahrung auch
gemacht und im Studium ist dann immer
mehr dieser Gedanke gereift dass ich in
Besatz möchte die viel familiärer ist
und so habe ich mich da für die Tender
entschieden weil ich das
Aufgabenspektrum ganz cool
finde und weil ich hier einfach wirklich
und das kann ich jetzt das kann ich
jetzt
bezeugen Teil einer familiären Besatzung
geworden
bin die Seefahrt ist auch heute noch ein
Abenteuer und auch die Momente echter
Seefahrerromantik gibt es noch doch sie
sind eher selten und kurz denn
gleichzeitig gilt es auf Kriegsschiffen
eine permanente Vorsicht walten zu
lassen vem dann wenn russische
aufklärungsschiffe versuchen per Funk
mit hackerangffen Daten abzugreifen aus
Computersystemen oder Smartphones der
Besatzung Aufklärung gehört zum Geschäft
in jeder Marine doch in der Ostsee ist
sie seit dem Überfall auf die Ukraine
schärfer geworden immer wieder müssen
Schiffskommandanten dann schnell handeln
wir haben hier verschiedene russische
Fahrzeuge im Seegebiet unter anderem
auch
seefernaufklärer die viele Möglichkeiten
besitzen in der Sensorik um militärische
Fahrzeuge aufzuklären und deren Daten
auch gegebenenfalls abzufassen wenn
diese sich nicht richtig schützen und
das ist natürlich auch einer der Gründe
warum ich hier während der Seefahrt
häufiger befohlen habe dass die privaten
Telefone abgeschaltet werden das gehört
zu einer militärischen Übung dazu aber
auch im Realbetrieb ist das ein Szenario
das auch häufiger mal
vorkommt über ein gehacktes Smartphone
kann auf Soldaten Druck ausgeübt werden
im ukrainekrieg wird diese Taktik von
russischen Streitkräften eingesetzt
Bewegungsprofile können mit Hilfe der
Handys erstellt werden und Aufschluss
über Routen von Kriegsschiffen geben
oder wo sich natoeinheiten begegnen wie
die Elbe und der polnische Versorger
kontraadmiral Xavi tniitki geprobt
werden soll ein
schleppmanöver doch das Schleppseil der
Elbe ist zu dick für die
tanitki und auch das Umgekehrte Manöver
muss vorzeitig abgebrochen werden die
multinationale Zusammenarbeit in der
NATO läuft nicht immer rund nicht selten
aufgrund unterschiedlicher technischer
Systeme der Streitkräfte der
verschiedenen
[Musik]
Mitgliedsstaaten
am Abend beginnt Katrins Schicht auf der
Brücke sie ist obermart und
navigationsunteroffizier wir haben zwar
die elektronische Sekarte aber wir haben
immer als Backup immer noch die
papierseekarte immer so wie wie man das
von früher kennt auch papierseekarten
beinhalten alle relevanten Informationen
für die Seefahrt die Karte ist halt
nicht immer auf neuesten Stand also hier
z.B ist jetzt eine eine neue Gaspipeline
erstellt worden und daher diese ganzen
kleinen Punkte hier sieht man halt wo
sag mal so die Pipeline beginnt und wo
die dann
hinläuft und so haben wir halt ganz
viele verschiedene verschiedene Sachen
die wir die wir noch bearbeiten die wir
einfügen aber auch streichen also
löschen am Abend kommt am Horizont das
russische Aufklärungsschiff wieder in
Sicht solche Begegnungen zu
dokumentieren ist auch Teil der Aufgaben
des navigationsteams an Bord der
Elbe man sieht halt hier einfach ein
Schiff und dann machen wir verschiedene
Fotos und das ist halt immer mit
Absprache mit den ganzen wachoffizieren
Offizieren die jetzt gerade da sind oder
auch mit dem Kommandanten und dann gehe
ich meistens rein und zeigt dann die
Fotos und dann gucken die ob ich
eventuell noch mal was anderes machen
soll oder so Katrin zeigt die Aufnahme
dem fahrenden Wachoffizier hier sind die
516 ist der gleich ja der gleich he
morgen um das Schiff anhand seiner
silhette genauer identifizieren zu
können bearbeitet Katrin die Bilder am
Computer ich kann theoretisch jetzt noch
mal das Bild zuschneiden verschiedene
Filter verwenden damit man gucken kann
ob man vielleicht noch mal die
Helligkeit besser noch mal ändern kann
oder z hier Helligkeit verändern
Dunkelheit verändern wenn wir das dann
nachher fertig haben wir das dann zum
Funkraum und der Funkraum schickt das
dann an das marine Kommando Katrin
vermerkt auch Ort und Zeit der Sichtung
das russische Schiff hält erkennbar
Abstand zu den lettischen
Hoheitsgewässern und damit zur Elbe und
anderen natoeinheiten innerhalb der 12
Meilenzone
[Musik]
Lettlands
für die Nacht steuert die Elbe die Bucht
von Riga an fern ab von russischen
Marineeinheiten die Sicht nimmt ab eine
der Nacht das lagerbild draußen ist
nicht so leicht einsehbar wie bei
hichten
Tag wir fahren jetzt küstenähe in der
Bucht von Riga die sichere Navigation
ist
ist natürlich das A und O ähm und
aufgrund der geringen Sicht in der Nacht
das Lagebild auf dem Radar hier sehen
wir schön die Küstenlinie wir sind
relativ nah dran
damit wir einerseits
von den Wettereinflüssen ähm weiter
draußen geschützt sind und andererseits
unser Besatzung dann doch mal die Chance
eines äh eines guten Handynetzes bieten
können ähm ja ja damit auch mal das
Telefonat nach Hause dann doch drinne
istung rechts heraus blinkendes
Licht ich meldde mich jetzt ab ich gehe
auf
Kammer ich wünsche euch eine ruhige
Wache wir sehen uns
morgen oder später wenn ich nicht
schlafen kann
einw von
Brücke die Kajüte von Hendrik liegt
einige Decks tiefer
das Rotlicht ist im oberen Teil des
Treppenhauses der Elbe die einzige
Lichtquelle vor allem auf dem
umgekehrten Weg also auf die Brücke
hilft das damit sich die Augen an die
Dunkelheit
gewöhnen weil wenn es dann doch schon
mal finstere Nacht ist dann braucht das
eine Weile Neonlicht auf allen anderen
Decks im Rest V ist quasi immer noch
hellig der Tag bzw
ja einfach
standardhell weil auch nach
sonnuntergang viele an ihren
Bildschirmarbeitsplätzen
hängen so wie ich jetzt noch den Tages
Dienstplan für morgen zu bearbeiten habe
und auszuhängen habe Platz für eigene
Büroräume gibt es auf der Elbe nicht der
PC steht direkt neben dem Bett 40 cm
zwischen Kopfkissen und Tastatur da
fällt abschalten schwer selbst wenn man
sich schon schlafen gelegt hat wer mir
dann im schlimmsten Fall wieder bewusst
wird was habe ich denn noch alles
vergessen und dann irgendwie
11:30 dann doch noch mal aus dem Bock
komme um um irgendwas fertig zu machen
irgende E-Mail abzuschicken
ähm ja nicht ganz so leicht aber es
scheint anderen auch nicht leicht zu
fallen denn
sehr sehr oft gibt's auch mal E-Mails
die kommen die kommen nach der nach dem
Dienstschluss
vor all wenn irgendwie die andere Boote
in See send oder besetz S sind und meine
einw Kollegen auf anderen Einheiten dann
irgendwie um 23 Uhr irgendwas auch noch
mal eine E-Mail raus dann Dach ich so ja
ich fühle dich ich weiß wie das ist ja
raus aus der Uniform abschalten als
Kapitän Leutnant in einer Einzelkabine
die einzige Zeit für Hendrik in der er
privat sein
kann eins seiner großen Hobbys die
Fotografie an Bord bleibt Zeit die
eigenen Aufnahmen zu bearbeiten und dann
sind dann noch die
Tattoos sind seand Tattoos ich äh hab
klassischerweise das das das hold fast
auf den auf den Knöcheln tätowiert ich
finde es sehr sehr schön die Seemänner
früher auf ihren segelboden
die haben sich das H F auf die Knöchel
tätowiert weil es sie immer erinnern
sollten egal wie schlimm der Sturm ist
halt fest und überstehe das egal wie
schlimm der Sturm ist du schaffst das
wen du ich gut festhältst ähm das finde
ich finde ich sehr sehr schön aber die
vorschriftenlage ist halt relativ klar
ähm in der Öffentlichkeit muss ich es
jetzt bei Bus und Bahn fahren muss ich
beispielsweise alles abdecken oder bei
öffentlichen Gelöbnissen weil die
Vorschrift sagt auch dass es das
die Pflicht zum Abdecken an Bord von
Kriegsschiffen fät das macht mir halt
das Leben einfach ähm von daher Gehör
dazu wenn es sein muss klopft an seiner
Tür auch Nacht jemand an eine der
fahrwachen ist im Schichtbetrieb auf sie
immer im Dienst um Mitternacht war die
Wache von Katrin zu Ende sie ist auf dem
Weg von ihrer zweiersenkajüte in den
Fitnessraum
überall im Schiff Riegeln Schotten ganze
Bereiche hermetisch
ab Sport ist für Katrin wichtig eine der
wenigen Abwechslungen im
Bordalltag
wenn ich wirklich Bock habe wenn ich von
18 bis
0 Wache hatte dann gehe ich von 0 bis 2
oder so oder 0 bis 130 Uhr noch mal
Sport machen das ist halt je nachdem was
man für Wachen hatte was man vor allem
auch für Situation hatte was für Übung
wir gerade gefahren sind und das ist
halt immer ja tagesformatig würde ich
sagen mehrere Räume unter Deck im Heck
des Kriegsschiffs werden zum
Fitnessstudio umfunktioniert wenn es
dann halt wirklich voll wird kann es
halt sein dass wir bis zu hier unten
sind und das ist ja schon sehr kleiner
Raum von daher versuchen wir schon dass
wir hier so ein paar ein zwei Leute
unterbringen sag ich mal so dann einige
sind noch im Ruder Maschinenraum da kann
man auch noch so ein oder zwei Matten
hinlegen s dass man halt auch wirklich
Platz hat und sich dann so miteinander
absprechen und einteilen wirklich diese
diesen kleinen Platz den wir überhaupt
haben da es kaum andere Orte im Schiff
gibt um Sport zu treiben hilft die gute
Kameradschaft an Bord der Elbe sind auf
jeden Fall einige die
das Sport
[Applaus]
machen man muss natürlich gucken müssen
natürlich gucken wie das gerade mit den
fahrwachen läuft man versucht schon
aufinander Rücksicht zu nehmen katrin
hat einiges auf sich genommen um fit zu
werden für Ihren Traumjob bei der
Marine ich habe ganz viel abgenommen hab
60 kg und dadurch ist halt sag mal so
Sport ein Teil meines Lebens geworden
ein großer Teil meines Lebens undade
auch hier auf dem Schiff ist das
wirklich auch noch
mal ja
wirklich ein Ausgleich weil gerade so
wenn man die ganze Zeit auf Seewache ist
die ganze Zeit immer das gleiche sieht
da braucht man irgendwann auch mal
Abwechslung und dass man auch halt
wirklich mental auch mal runterkommt und
von daher ist halt Sport super
wichtig nach einer Nacht vor aner
beginnt früh morgens die Schicht in der
Heizerei also den Maschinenraum der
Start der Antriebsmaschine wird
vorbereitet hier ist der klassische
maschinentelegraph die direkte Steuerung
zu unserem Antriebsmotor hier wird
zentral gesteuert welcher Bereich des
Schiffes diesen Motor steuern kann zur
Zeit ist jetzt dieser maschinentelegraph
auf den Leitstand eingestellt später
wenn die Maschine klar zum ist wird die
Verbindung auf die Brücke geschaltet s
dass dann die Brücke die Kontrolle
natürlich zum Steuern und navigieren des
Schiffes hat von diesem Leitstand aus
wird die Gesam Schiffstechnik
gesteuert ich gehe jetzt noch mal durch
die Maschine überprüf den seklerzustand
da wir vor Anker liegen und alles in
sofort Bereitschaft sein sollte nur um
noch mal sicherzustellen wir stellen den
handimod bzw den antriebsdieselmotor
nach einem wolkprinzip seh klar das wäre
Wasser Öl Luft Kraftstoff und Elektrik
das überprüfe ich alles einmal seit gut
6 Jahren kennt Nico jede Schraube im
Maschinenraum der über 3300 PS starke
V12 Motor wird mit Druckluft
gestartet dass der antriebsdiesel läuft
kann man im Dauerlärm des Maschinenraums
kaum
hören mehrere Dieselgeneratoren laufen
hier nonstop um Strom für das Schiff zu
produzieren dass die Elbe lediglich eine
Antriebsmaschine hat ist für Nico kein
Grund zur Sorge der rund 30 Jahre Diesel
hat ihn noch nie im Stich gelassen der
springt gut an ja also der macht was er
soll und ja schnurrt wie ein Rottweiler
sage ich
immer während der Anker gelichtet wird
hat Nico Zeit fürs Frühstück in solchen
eher ruhigen Momenten sind Nicos
Gedanken auch immer wieder zu Hause vor
allem dann wenn er sich länger dort
nicht melden konnte
wenn es heiß auf einmal Handys ausmachen
der Russe ist in der Nähe damit halt die
keine Daten abfangen können und man
schreibt der Familie zu Hause du Handy
muss jetzt ausgemacht werden die Russen
sind in der Nähe macht Handy aus S ist
man drei Tage abgeschottet dann kann man
das Handy wieder anmachen dann hat man
noch mal drei Tage kein Empfang also da
möchte man sich nicht in die Lage nach
Hause versetzen was die gerade denken
was die durchmachen und man selbst dann
so sagt na ja wird schon nicht und dann
kriegt man doch wieder nach und dann
macht man sich schon ein bisschen
Gedanken aber selbst wenn es so wäre man
könnte es nicht ändern dafür habe ich
unterschrieben das ist mein Job aber ich
hoffe es wird nicht so weit
[Musik]
kommen